hello so today i have a special guest
mike still
mike is and he's going to introduce
himself and provide more details but i
believe he is
uh english british
if i'm not he'll correct me if i'm wrong
correct and
and he is a not only a speaker of arabic
at least one dialect and so i want to
find out more about learning arabic his
experience his recommendations what to
do what not to do and so forth so
mike welcome
thank you very much pleasure to be here
thanks steve
now could you give us a brief
introduction where you are your
interests
and and something about how you got into
arabic
absolutely
so yes i am from the uk that's where i
am now
and uh i grew up in the southwest of the
uk
i studied in southampton university i
did a physics degree
so not particularly language related but
i did always have this interest in
languages going back to a young age i
didn't go abroad for a very long time
so it wasn't until i was about 14 15 and
i went to france with school so you know
across the english channel to france
with school
and i never really had much experience
with other languages up until that point
i've made up for it since and i spent a
lot of time traveling abroad so i've
always been passionate and interested in
languages and i've always just found it
very fascinating to hear other languages
and i always wanted to understand what
other people were saying
so my specific interest with arabic came
probably as early as when i was at
university although we did have the odd
arabic lesson at school when i was kind
of 15 16 years old i had a friend at
university who was from oman
and i would always be asking him to
teach me
little words here and there hello
thank you you're welcome all these kind
of things
and then it wasn't until i moved abroad
with my work i trained as a teacher and
i found myself living in kuwait the
middle east that i really started to
take it um even more seriously
and i started studying arabic fosha
and when i was in the middle east there
was no better opportunity or better
excuse to to learn the arabic so i
started taking it a bit more a bit more
seriously then and we can talk all about
that sure can i ask you a few questions
then so what year were you in kuwait
so i moved out to kuwait
in 2016.
okay i'm pretty sure 2016. yeah okay so
four years ago or so so i'm trying to
picture
say because i'm now interested in arabic
so if you go to kuwait yes uh and you
study fusa
so my question is how widespread is fusa
by the way for
non-arabic
keeners
is i guess it's not exactly standard
arabic i get confused you can call it
some people say well fuso is actually
the language of the quran or it's not or
it's not standard arabic or whatever
call it modern standard arabic and you
can explain the differences yeah but so
how common is that in kuwait if you're
learning that at school and your
teachers are teaching you fusa
what is the opportunity then to use that
in kuwait with people who live there
that's a good question
the short answer is not at all common
and this is we're kind of hitting the
nail on the head here with
with one of i guess the
the barriers or the the struggles with
learning arabic because
kuwaiti dialect is very different from
the msa yeah and i agree with you we
should really call it modern standard
arabic fossa i get in trouble as well
and like if you're watching this please
bear in mind that you're talking to
you you're watching you're listening to
two non-natives uh try and explain
arabic and we're kind of in the learning
process ourselves so right i've always
lumped her and modern standard arabic in
the same kind of group
but there are subtle differences so
we'll continue referring it to as kind
of the formal modern standard arabic and
then colloquial so out in kuwait
kuwait is a mixed bag of so many people
only one third of the population is
kuwaiti there's loads of brits americans
indians people from all over the world
who go and work there and everyone well
not everyone but a lot of people try and
learn a bit of arabic so in in my
experience
my most common
uh i guess um
test subjects for practicing my arabic
were my students to be honest and of
course they were from not just kuwait
but from egypt from
uh all over the middle east syria well
that's what i was thinking about
countries saudi so there was a real mix
there
i was going to say there it wouldn't
just be foreigners i mean as in
non-arabic foreigners you'd have
palestinians you'd have egyptians people
going there to work because they got
money and they need the workforce
exactly right those other arabs then
they will learn
the kuwaiti language or how do they
communicate
well the rule at school because i taught
in a british school was that they should
speak english but they would communicate
typically in i guess what would be a
mixed bag of uh egyptian arabic gulf
arabic but more common than not because
the english levels of all the students
was pretty high the common language was
english so i would i would kind of
bounce things off my students
and say you know
and they would say so we don't say that
and that sounds really stupid and i
would have a laugh with them and
and gradually bit by bit i would then
piece together these the slang the
colloquial the the kuwaiti slang
language of kuwaiti
and kind of try and it's almost like
you're learning two languages parallel
to one another uh right
let's just let's just stop ourselves
there it's it's not really slang like
it's a language i studied mandarin in
hong kong and nobody spoke mandarin in
1968 it was all cantonese but cantonese
is a language it's not just a slang
you know lebanese they have a language
uh
although the written form is is the
standard arabic right so it's it's again
but that's similar to chinese the
written form is the same regardless of
whether it's shanghainese cantonese or
whatever
so yeah you're there you're learning
you're presumably going to a language
school for your arabic
yes yeah there was a language school
that was organized yeah as part of the
school yeah
oh i see as part of the school and did a
lot of the teachers take arabic
small amount small amount yeah most
people just want to go and uh teach and
do the work and then go to the health
club etc
so if you're in kuwait and you're
learning uh modern standard arabic um at
least the television is in modern
standard arabic or some of the programs
on the radio
that's correct yes right
so just to explain to people like so
that so would it would all of the radio
television and newspapers in other words
all the media would be in standard
arabic
and people speak to each other in
whatever
regional language they're most
comfortable with is that the situation
pretty much yes so
so i would listen to a radio station
called
marina fm
and i think it was like 888 frequency or
something i guess would that be a long
wave and uh and
the the general rule is yes that in the
media whether it's news or newspapers
they speak and write the
modern standard arabic the formal arabic
now the difficulty comes when you're a
news broadcaster or an entertainment
station and you're having phone-ins
with kuwaitis
and then you get the the dj i guess the
dj sounds old-fashioned now but you get
the dj talking to the the
the the person who's calling in
whoever's presenting the show and
because they're just two kuwaitis
talking they
you hear some of the colloquialisms
and then they come back in so i was
hearing bits of that so it's a slightly
it is on a scale between the formal
formal and then the slightly less formal
and then of course that goes down to in
the kuwaiti family and i have a few
kuwaiti friends and uh you know they
invited me to their house and and to to
hear them speak within themselves that's
kind of the far colloquial end so it's a
bit of a scale but yeah the media is in
the msa and then when you go down to
just family and friends yeah it'd be
totally um pretty much
a different language yeah
but then to add to the sort of
schizophrenic nature of the arabic
language
presumably uh you know soap operas and
dramas and
you know those kinds of programs on
television not the news or you know
serious discussions but about sort of
entertainment sitcoms or whatever they
would a lot of them would be in egyptian
or lebanese arabic right
yes
kuwaiti production uh no that there are
kuwaiti dramas and you know that they're
probably only watched by a few hundred
thousand people so they're kind of low
budget but they would then be presented
in the kuwaiti dialect
right so it really is a minefield to to
also
yeah but don't they also watch a lot of
egyptian and lebanese uh productions as
well um
well
probably but in my experience
having dealt with the thing is uh
the english language level is pretty
high in kuwait
and
i would say i mean this is a guess and
maybe the kuwaitis watching this can can
confirm or deny in the comments but i
would guess that most kuwaitis would
watch like american shows youtube
netflix or kuwaiti i'm sure there are
some that would watch egyptian shows
because because egyptian egyptians are
kind of like the
entertainment center of the middle east
from what i understand the disney films
etc but there's a lot of american stuff
being watched and the english levels are
pretty high so they tend to watch that
yeah
okay now let's move along
uh what when you started into arabic
what were the
you know what are the difficulties were
you concerned at one point that you
wouldn't be able to overcome these
difficulties and how did you overcome
them
absolutely i was
i was concerned i thought this is an
impossible task um there's no way
what what specifically well to get to
the level that i wanted to get to which
was to be able to understand and speak
arabic i just thought i'm going to spend
months i mean at this point i was
thinking weeks months years i'm going to
spend weeks months and years
and i'm going to have nothing to show
for it and i thought it would kind of i
thought it might be a waste of my time
and for those people that you know were
kind of watching me learn as well
i would have just seemed to have failed
now
of course
you you don't notice the progress you're
making and i've talked about this in
some of my videos that because you're
watching yourself learn in real time
you don't see the small steps the small
bits of progress and really it's just
overcoming that gradually how did i
overcome it
i basically tried to just
i mean the thing is if you enjoy doing
something then it's not work and i know
that you yourself as a polyglot will
understand this yes for you learning a
language isn't work it's just part of
your day it's enjoyable it's it's it's
something that you get pleasure from
and i felt very much
like that in that
i would
i would integrate it so that it didn't
feel like work i take the same approach
to things like exercise it seems like
maybe an interesting comparison but if
i'm exercising and i'm hating it and i'm
all sweating a lot i'm never doing this
again then i'm not going to do it again
so i'd rather just do something really
light and easy than nothing at all and
it's the same with languages i'd rather
just watch uh 20 minutes of
arabic speaking youtube video
and not kind of be bogged down and tired
and struggling with it than do nothing
at all so it's right it's being
realistic with your expectations
and then
and not pushing it so hard that it kind
of puts you off it so that was my
approach yeah you got to keep that uh
that fire that flame burning sometimes
if you push it too hard the flame goes
out
uh exactly yeah exactly when i started
the to me the biggest obstacle was the
writing system
uh because you know four different forms
of the same letter depending on where
it's located in the word
uh you know letters that are pronounced
differently depending on any number of
things
uh i decided not to learn the little uh
you know acronyms that designate the
consonants because i have
you know audio on on on the computer i
have text to speech i'll just listen to
it and sure so and but now i find that
you know it's just it's just amazing how
the brain gets used to things
so i eventually i'm i'm not at your
level but i'm more and more getting used
to it i just wanted to point out too
that you do have a youtube channel we
will leave a link in the description box
i was interviewed by you for your
youtube channel not too long ago
and it's a place where people can find
information advice resources
encouragement explanation etc all
related to learning arabic and uh what
is the name of your youtube channel
my youtube name is now just mike still
so much so
m-i-k-e-s-t-i-l-l yeah okay the old name
was arabic mike so if you search for
arabic mike you'll find it as well but
yeah mike still is the name of my
channel
okay
and i i think i mean arabic is there's
what 350 400 million speakers
uh it's a it's a language that has had a
profound influence on history because uh
you know having also
studied turkish and persian
there's 10 15 arabic words in those
languages obviously the muslim religion
which was brought to a good part of the
world by
uh
arabs
and with it their language i mean it's
just a
and there's a whole bunch of history
there's so much that that relates to the
arab
the arabic language not to mention the
political situation today learning their
language brings those people to life
makes them not just uh stereotypes but
makes them real people and but of course
you lived in an arab country so you have
a different perspective than i have but
a very worthwhile language to learn and
absolutely yeah
you may want to add to that
well no just that you know
just to bring up one of your earlier
points about how you know which language
to learn and why arabic and what are the
benefits of learning arabic
yeah i mean
it is i mean it depends on how you judge
it but it's certainly in the top um five
languages spoken as a second language at
least and
you're
you're never going to struggle to find
someone who speaks arabic in order to
practice speaking with for me i had the
added benefit of
working in the middle east so
i i mean i i didn't just spend the year
in kuwait i also went to jordan and uh i
spent some time there
and i then worked in dubai so i've spent
a bit of time in that way but no it's
it's a worthwhile language to learn
there's so many arab speakers and uh if
you're if you have any kind of
contact or connection to that part of
the world whether it's through work
whether it's through a friend it's it's
definitely
a worthwhile language to learn in that
way because they'll really appreciate
the effort you've made
and you can build those connections and
for me it was all about building those
connections with the people who speak it
because they're quite um
because it's quite unusual to to have
someone learn the language it it it goes
even further with them and they really
do appreciate and they love to talk
about their language they're very
passionate about it
okay so then let me ask you a question
that i kind of struggle with so you were
in jordan so that's
levantine arabic you were in dubai
that's gulf arabic
yeah kuwait i guess is gulf arabic i
don't know or is it closer to iraqi
arabic i don't know so when you are are
in those different places what form of
arabic do you use to communicate with
people
um
so
i would
well so in jordan uh i did a i i did a
language school at um part of the
university there um for about for a
month and
having studied fosa um
then
or msa arabic i then added to my kind of
uh toolkit the the jordanian so i would
try and use my jordanian
um
levant phrases now was that difficult to
do once you had the fusa to develop an
ability in in say the jordanian
uh arabic was that a a lot of work a lot
of time or a fairly easy transition it
i wouldn't say it was difficult but it
was it was frustrating because there i
there i was learning all these words and
doing my flash cards and trying to drill
a thousand two thousand three thousand
words into my head and then i'm given a
new set of words for all of those words
so it is a challenge and it's something
that can
could potentially put people off
but
it also
makes you
it really gives you an appreciation for
the the history the structure and the
depth of the language and to see how it
all fits together
um
is really is really rewarding because
there's
i mean i wish i could think of some some
examples off the cuff but there are so
many words
which of course originate from the
standard arabic and then have been
borrowed from here there and then have
been slightly translated into this
meaning and to see that all come
together
it's a challenge but it's it's
fascinating if you are interested in
languages so that there's no better
language to learn um
you know
from from my perspective than the arabic
and how deep you can go with it
i must say that my brief exposure to 11
arabic egyptian arabic i can see how it
connects to standard arabic
so like i don't remember i haven't done
a lot but instead of saying cathedra
they say
like they seem to you know compress a
lot of these words and they have
and they have all kinds of other words
there
uh i think we have lost our contact in
our zoom you know uh i'll just explain
here i
we were communicating via the internet
via zoom here we are we're back okay way
back so we're just yeah but we're
actually talking to our iphones you know
maybe we should end it there maybe we
should try now i've been doing a lot of
persian so my arabic is very very rusty
but i think people would be very uh
disappointed if we didn't at least try
how would you say
you know i've totally forgotten
[Music]
um
it's very interesting i've forgotten i
was doing better before i've been away
from it but you can talk say something
to the audience in arabic
um
[Music]
were
um
britannia
[Music]
wherever you are in the world
you can
find resources and you can just do it
bit by bit and keep up the studying
video
video
a
so with that now we've lost mike again
because it's that's why we do these on
our smartphones so that we've just gone
down in the uh unfortunately internet
connection is uh not so good
i'm still waiting for it to come back
uh oh we've lost it entirely i'm going
to end it here i think we have
everything
he said what he wanted to say i thank
mike very much
and i will stop it here and i apologize
for my rusty arabic i haven't spoken for
a while i think if i got back into it i
would improve fairly quickly because i
do a lot of listening but there you have
it bye for now
[Music]
you